أعتقد أنه من المأساوي والمروع أن
جنوب أفريقيا قررت أن تلعب دور
المدافع عن الشيطان
وأن تكون بمثابة الذراع القانوني لحزب
الله.  أطلب منك أن ترد
بإجابة لا علاقة لها بالسؤال،
حسنًا، دعني أجيب مباشرة،
فالمحامي هناك الذي يعمل
كممثل قانوني لحماس والذي
يتهم إسرائيل بارتكاب إبادة جماعية
يقدم واقعًا مقلوبًا رأسًا على عقب
حيث لا وجود لحماس.  لم
تأخذ رهائن، قررت إسرائيل ذات
صباح مشرق أن تبدأ قصف غزة في
السابع من أكتوبر، لقد عانينا من عمل من أعمال الإبادة الجماعية، لقد
عانينا من عمل من أعمال الإبادة الجماعية عندما
غزت حماس بلدنا، أريد أن أسألك
عن هذه التعليقات التي أدلى بها
السياسيون الإسرائيليون منذ السابع من أكتوبر و
نأمل أن نتمكن من عرض الاقتباسات
هنا، نحن هذا رئيسكم، إنها
أمة بأكملها هناك وهي
مسؤولة أه إنه يشير إلى جارين أه،
ألق نظرة على هذا، الصورة التالية التي
نقوم الآن بطرحها في غزة
كنار نبار كما يعرف الناس هي  مصطلح للكارثة
أه بعد حرب 1948 حرب
يستخدمها الفلسطينيون حول
التطهير العرقي وكلنا لدينا هدف واحد مشترك وهو
محو قطاع غزة من على
وجه الأرض هل ترى لماذا
يعتقد البعض أنك لا
تريد الفلسطينيين على الإطلاق  لفترة أطول في
غزة